Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Ti proteggerò dalle paure delle ipocondrie
Dai turbamenti che da oggi
incontrerai per la tua via.
Dalle ingiustizie
e dagli inganni del tuo tempo
Dai fallimenti che per tua natura
normalmente attirerai
Ti solleverò dai dolori
e dai tuoi sbalzi d'umore
Dalle ossessioni delle tue manie
Supererò le correnti gravitazionali
Lo spazio e la luce
per non farti invecchiare
E guarirai da tutte le malattie
Perché sei un essere speciale
Ed io, avrò cura di te
Vagavo per i campi del Tennessee
Come vi ero arrivato, chissà
Non hai fiori bianchi per me?
Più veloci di aquile,
i miei sogni attraversano il mare
Ti porterò soprattutto
il silenzio e la pazienza
Percorreremo assieme
le vie che portano all'essenza
I profumi d'amore
inebrieranno i nostri corpi
La bonaccia d'agosto
non calmerà i nostri sensi
Tesserò i tuoi capelli
come trame di un canto
Conosco le leggi del mondo,
e te ne farò dono
Supererò le correnti gravitazionali
Lo spazio e la luce
per non farti invecchiare
Ti salverò da ogni malinconia
Perche sei un essere speciale
Ed io avrò cura di te
Io sì, che avrò cura di te
(Applausi)
Grazie, e benvenuti.
Allora, "Non hai fiori bianchi per me?".
Cantando questa canzone -
come mi capita spesso
di fare, ultimamente -
ho sempre la sensazione
come di porgere la mano a qualcuno,
come quando ci si avvicina
a un animale, a un cucciolo impaurito,
e si tenta di accarezzarlo.
E immagino che forse accade la stessa cosa
a voi, a chi sta, a chi ascolta,
al pubblico che ascolta la canzone.
Perché di fatto, già questo
è un prendersi cura l'uno dell'altro:
io mi sono preso cura di voi
e voi, nell'ascolto,
vi siete presi cura di me.
Ho conosciuto Franco Battiato
alla fine degli anni '90.
Nonostante la frequentazione
non fosse esattamente assidua,
per motivi legati al lavoro
e anche per una certa differenza di età.
Però ci sentivamo spesso:
ci si telefonava,
ci si scriveva, eccetera.
E quando mi capitava di andare a trovarlo
a Milano, o in Sicilia,
era sempre un momento in cui succedeva
qualcosa di particolare.
Non necessariamente di eclatante,
ma come se la sua presenza
mi mettesse nelle condizioni
di osservare il mondo
da un altro punto di vista,
perché era una personalità
veramente molto forte.
E quando lo incontravo,
quando ero lì con lui,
lui mi faceva sempre
delle domande molto semplici,
che faceva a me o agli altri amici
che erano presenti con me.
Ed erano domande del tipo: "Come stai?"
"Stai realizzando i tuoi sogni?";
"Come va la vita?";
"Come stanno i tuoi amici?";
"Come stanno i tuoi parenti?"
Il bello era che non erano
domande di circostanza,
ma erano domande alle quali
lui si aspettava sempre una risposta;
e quindi era lì, con le mani conserte,
che aspettava che io rispondessi.
Ed era un atteggiamento molto simile
a quello che hanno i nostri genitori,
i nostri nonni, i nostri parenti,
le persone che ci vogliono bene.
Quindi, diciamo che Franco si prendeva -
iniziava a prendersi cura degli amici
a partire da questi gesti così semplici.
E non era scontato, non è mai scontato,
soprattutto per una persona
di quella generazione,
di quell'età e di quel successo.
E spesso capitava che,
quando io rispondevo a queste domande,
lui facesse un sorriso,
poi si avvicinasse,
e ci dava, così,
una piccola carezza sul viso.
E quando penso a quel gesto
penso, in realtà
che Franco non si sentisse
assolutamente un essere speciale.
Non si sentiva affatto speciale.
Perché?
Il bello della sua frequentazione
era che - noi lo consideriamo oggi,
e lo consideravamo allora,
una persona speciale
in virtù del fatto
che ci ha insegnato molte cose,
che ha cantato delle canzoni stupende,
che ha scritto dei testi incredibili.
Ma lui non si sentiva così speciale:
ed era in realtà la sua presenza,
che faceva sentire speciale noi.
E quindi io mi sono reso conto
che prendersi cura di una persona
vuol dire proprio questo:
fare in modo che noi diventiamo speciali,
con la presenza e con il prendersi cura
della persona che abbiamo di fronte.
Questo accade, spesso,
perché le persone che ci vogliono bene
ci chiedono aiuto
quando hanno bisogno di aiuto;
e quindi, a volte,
anche per semplice distrazione
queste persone non sanno
di essere speciali per noi,
perché altrimenti sarebbe
molto più facile.
In realtà, loro si sentono
proprio in difetto nei nostri confronti.
Ma è proprio questo loro atteggiamento
che fa in modo che noi aumentiamo
il nostro livello di comprensione,
anche di noi stessi.
È come un po' quando accade
una reazione chimica,
e dall'incontro di due elementi
nasce un terzo elemento,
a volte anche inaspettatamente.
Quindi accade qualcosa
di ovviamente naturale,
ma che io trovo sempre straordinario.
Dunque, tornando alla canzone,
"La cura" è una canzone
che molti di voi sicuramente,
e molti di tutti -
molta gente, insomma -
chi l'ha ascoltata, chi la conosce -
la reputa una canzone molto bella,
perché appunto piace a molti;
ma questo, diremmo che non basta,
a definire qualcosa bello.
Il fatto che piaccia a molti di voi
non basta a definire "La cura"
come una canzone bella.
Se in effetti scendessero per strada,
e fermassimo delle persone,
e chiedessimo loro
che cos'è la bellezza,
sicuramente avremmo
delle risposte molto diverse;
e sicuramente, molti ci direbbero
non che cosa è la bellezza,
ma che cos'è che gli piace,
qual è il loro gusto personale.
Però, se noi tutti in questa sala
decidessimo che un mostro a tre teste,
un mostro orrendo a tre teste,
è bello,
vorrebbe dire che è bello?
No, non è così.
In effetti, definire che cos'è la bellezza
è una questione annosa.
Molti filosofi, e non solo,
hanno tentato di spiegare
che cos'è la bellezza
in 2000 anni di storia della filosofia -
e non solo: di storia dell'arte, eccetera.
Quindi, definire la bellezza
è una questione molto spinosa;
e non tutti ci sono riusciti.
Alcuni filosofi,
come Kant, Hegel eccetera,
hanno dato delle definizioni
molto belle e molto importanti
che sono, e restano,
quelle fondamentali fino a oggi.
Altri, invece, hanno dato
delle definizioni molto strampalate.
Ma torniamo un attimo a Battiato
per poi tornare alla bellezza.
Dunque, nel 1982 è l'anno
in cui "La voce del padrone"
ha avuto un successo strepitoso,
vendendo più di 1.000.000 di copie.
Nel 1982 avevo cinque anni;
e mi ricordo che andavo in giro
con mia madre, nella sua '500,
dove dentro c'era la cassettina
de "La voce del padrone".
Io ero un bambino,
quindi non capivo
quasi assolutamente niente
di quello che Battiato cantava:
"Gesuiti euclidei,
vestiti come dei bonzi..."
Boh.
E mi ricordo che facevo
delle associazioni,
anche piuttosto strane.
Mi ricordo che mia madre si lamentava
perché non riusciva a farsi
la permanente in casa -
perché i bigodini non bastavano.
Oppure, quando parcheggiava la macchina
diceva: no, qui c'è
un divieto di sosta permanente.
Poi c'era la cassettina in macchina
che diceva: "Cerco un centro
di gravità permanente"
Una roba un po' strana, che non capivo.
Quindi, piano piano - cinque anni,
dieci anni, dodici anni, 15 anni -
quando diventa adolescente,
diventato adolescente,
comincio a farmi delle grandi domande;
e quindi comincio ad approfondire.
E per esempio, scopro il filosofo
che Battiato ha seguito
e che ha studiato, che è Gurdjieff,
dal quale poi ha tratto, anche,
"Centro di gravità permanente".
Dopo questo studio,
e questo approfondimento,
ho cominciato anche a cantare;
e mi dicevano, è successa una cosa strana
perché alcuni amici in comune,
poi anche con Franco,
mi dicevano che cantando io trasmettevo
lo stesso tipo di emotività
che trasmetteva Franco.
Non so se questo è vero:
voi adesso mi avete sentito,
io spero di sì, che vi abbia trasmesso
anche un millesimo di quello
che riusciva a trasmettere Franco.
Però, di fatto, questi amici
mi dicevano questa cosa,
mi spingevano a farlo.
Questo per me era motivo
di grande gioia, naturalmente:
perché accidenti, insomma,
riuscire a cantare come Battiato
era una cosa piuttosto importante;
ma allo stesso tempo era un problema,
quasi un problema psicologico,
perché stavamo parlando
della mia personalità,
e quindi io in qualche modo
mi sentivo un po' annullato:
Ma chi sono?
Chi sono io?
Non sono Battiato.
In effetti, però, negli anni,
quando sono cresciuto,
continuando a studiare, a leggere,
a studiare Battiato soprattutto,
mi sono reso conto che forse
non ero così tanto diverso
da un pianista che interpreta
un grande compositore.
Al di là, poi, degli ordini di grandezza.
Quindi, di fatto io
mi sentivo un interprete:
ma forse anche qualcosa di più,
avendo conosciuto Franco,
avendolo frequentato.
Mi sono reso conto che, forse,
avrei dovuto prendermi cura
della sua opera.
Perché ci si può prendere
cura di una persona,
e ci si può prendere cura di un animale
o di una pianta, eccetera;
ma ci si può anche prendere cura
di un'opera, in generale,
delle canzoni di Franco.
E così, mi sono ritrovato da adulto
a fare questo mestiere:
e ho scoperto, per esempio,
cantando e studiando le canzoni di Franco,
alcune analogie importanti.
E torniamo alla bellezza,
perché nelle canzoni di Franco
c'è una bellezza incredibile
che ci porta in un luogo magico
e molto importante,
che riguarda anche proprio la cura stessa.
Dunque, Franco quando canta,
e quando scrive i testi,
raggiunge delle vette mistiche
molto importanti e spirituali, molto alte.
Facciamo degli esempi:
per esempio, in una canzone
che si intitola "E ti vengo a cercare"
lui dice: "Vorrei cambiare
l'oggetto dei miei desideri,
essere l'uno al di sopra
del bene e del male,
essere un'immagine divina
di questa realtà".
Ma alla fine della canzone, Franco dice:
"E ti vengo a cercare,
perché sto bene con te".
Lo stesso vale per un'altra canzone
molto bella, che si chiama "L'animale",
in cui parla dei quattro elementi -
l'acqua, la terra, il fuoco, l'aria -
e quindi comunque attorno a questi,
a questa mistica,
questa spiritualità così alta.
Ma alla fine della canzone, torna a dire:
"Ma l'animale che mi porto dentro,
nonostante non mi faccia
vivere felice mai, vuole te".
Dunque nelle canzoni di Battiato
c'è quella che io chiamo un estetica pura:
non una bellezza esteriore,
ma un'estetica pura.
Perché estetica, pensate,
è una parola che è stata coniata
perché viene da un vocabolo greco
che è "aisthesis", e che vuol dire
"sensazione, sensibilità".
Quindi, la bellezza non è qualcosa
che riguarda l'apparenza delle cose,
come tutti spesso siamo portati a pensare.
Assolutamente no.
La bellezza è qualcosa che riguarda,
innanzitutto, la sensibilità.
E la sensibilità
è quel grande dono che noi abbiamo,
che ci porta non al giudizio di qualcosa,
a dire "Questo è bello, quello è brutto,
questo mi piace, questo non mi piace";
ma la sensibilità, e quindi l'estetica,
è, dicevo, quel grande dono
che ci porta alla conoscenza.
Dunque, se la sensibilità è quel dono
che ci porta alla conoscenza,
quando noi ci prendiamo cura di qualcuno
non stiamo facendo un atto sensibile
verso questa persona.
Quindi, io trovo che
proprio in questo senso,
la cura sia strettamente
legata alla bellezza.
Quindi, prendersi cura di qualcuno
vuol dire fare in modo
che in questa relazione,
nell'incontro tra due persone -
come se fosse, come dicevo prima,
una reazione chimica -
nell'incontro tra due persone
oppure tra una persona e un'opera d'arte,
tra una persona e un animale,
tra un animale o un animale,
insomma tra due eventi, diciamo così,
in questa relazione
non può che nascere la bellezza.
Ma la relazione nasce, ed è tale,
proprio quando l'uno
si prende cura dell'altro.
E quando uno si prende cura dell'altro,
in genere nascono anche quelle
che consideriamo le preoccupazioni.
Però, io direi che non conviene mai
preoccuparsi di qualcuno, di qualcosa;
ma invece conviene occuparsi.
E qual è la differenza
tra preoccuparsi e occuparsi?
Beh, preoccuparsi vuol dire avere sempre
un tipo di sentimento
in qualche modo negativo.
Perché anche se ci preoccupiamo
di qualcosa di bello,
per esempio pensate a quando -
molti di voi avranno figli
che sono all'Università;
e quando stanno facendo un esame,
immagino che siate preoccupati.
Per una cosa bella, eh,
magari l'esame va bene;
ma di fatto siete preoccupati,
ovvero avete un po' d'ansia.
Anch'io, adesso, sono un po' ansioso,
perché ero preoccupato
che il TED andasse bene, eccetera.
Invece non bisogna essere così.
Quando ci si prende cura di una persona,
bisogna "occuparsene":
e cioè avere uno stato attivo.
Perché è soltanto occupandosi
di qualcuno, o di qualcosa
che si possono cambiare
le cose attivamente.
E non stare lì con l'ansia,
nella preoccupazione,
perché non cambierà assolutamente niente.
Per esempio, io che scrivo anche canzoni,
e conosco tanti artisti, eccetera,
mi rendo conto, per esempio,
che la creazione
è esattamente un occuparsi.
Quindi, quando noi scriviamo qualcosa,
quando parliamo con qualcuno, eccetera,
ci stiamo occupando;
e anche questo, di fatto,
è un prendersi cura.
E bisogna liberarsi assolutamente
di quei pensieri neri,
di quelle ansie eccetera.
Quindi, diventa chiaro
che avere paura di qualcuno, di qualcosa,
non può prescindere da una relazione.
Come per esempio: innaffiare una pianta,
come dicevo prima; prendersene cura;
vederla crescere;
tirare via le foglie morte;
capire qual è la temperatura giusta
per quella pianta
nell'ambiente in cui vive, etc.
Dunque, in una relazione
la cosa importante
è quanto riusciamo a elevarci,
quanto riusciamo a elevarci noi stessi
e quanto si riesce a elevarsi,
diciamo così, la coppia nella relazione;
perché il risultato, in questo movimento,
in questo grande incontro
che sono tutte le relazioni,
anche tra me e voi,
il risultato è la nascita della bellezza.
Questa è la cosa più importante.
Potreste dirmi che, a volte,
prendersi cura di qualcuno
non è proprio così bello,
quando abbiamo a che fare, per esempio,
con persone che sono malate,
che hanno delle malattie -
e quindi, prendersi cura
del fisico delle persone
non è spesso un'azione molto semplice.
Però, io penso che se invece si crea
quella relazione così importante,
che dicevo, così elevata,
di affetto, di reciproca stima, ecc.
allora credo che si possano superare
anche quelle sofferenze.
E come dice la canzone,
"Ti porterò soprattutto
il silenzio e la pazienza".
E per finire, io direi
che in tutto questo,
questa nascita della bellezza
all'interno della relazione,
bisognerebbe sempre pensare
che è importante trovare,
dentro lo sguardo di tutti,
una sorta di brillantezza,
che è una grande dote dell'umanità,
in una specie di oscillazione
che ci rende tutti appartenenti
allo stesso mondo,
e cioè alla natura.
Ed è così che la compassione
per ogni essere cosciente
ci rivela tutta la bellezza dell'universo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)